Okay, so let's do now an active power quiz. Suppose we have a processor whose
voltage can be changed between 0.9 and 1.5
volts in 0.1 volt steps. Its frequency can
be changed between 1.8 gigahertz and 3 gigahertz
in 0.2 gigahertz steps. But there is a
relationship between the voltage and the frequency you
have to use. If we want to use
the lowest frequency setting, our voltage can be 0.9 volts. If we want to use
the next frequency setting of 2.0 gigahertz, then the voltage needs to be 1.0
volts. For 2.2 gigahertz, we need to use 1.1 volts and so on. And
we can only get the highest 3 gigahertz with the highest voltage of 0.1 volts.
So, we can not just lower the voltage and increase
the frequency. If you increase the frequency, you also have
to increase the voltage. Of course, you are allowed to
use a 2 gigahertz frequency setting with any voltage that
is 1.0 volts or above. So we could, for example,
do 2 gigahertz and 1.5 volts, although that's, of course,
going to be less power efficient than using the lowest
voltage available for that frequency. Let's say also that we have
measured the power consumption at 1 volt
and 2 gigahertz, this setting here. And we
have found that the processor consumes 30
watts of power. The questions for you are,
what is the power for the most
power-efficient setting among these? Put your answer here.
And what is the power for the
highest-performance setting among these? Put your answer here.